[Music]
hello, how are you, Sala y
Jaramillo greets you with your report for today,
Wednesday, January 6. Firefighters managed to
get a person out of a
burning house near Rancho and Alta streets
shortly before midnight. The fire
broke out in  Vandalia Street and
firefighters found the victim
unconscious in one of the rooms
so far the condition
of the woman or what was the cause of the
fire is unknown and in another incident near the
center several streets near the
federal court had to be closed
After the police found a
suspicious package in the area,
police officers reported that they found no
explosives in the package and the streets have already
been reopened. The federal court was
the site of an anti-demonstration
this morning and this morning a new
traffic signal.  it was activated at one of
the busiest and busiest intersections in
the valley this is the same one
where a fatal accident happened
yesterday afternoon  Near Sahara
and When You Were streets, east of Aguas Avenue,
police agents reported that a
young driver approached the
intersection and was hit by a
motorcyclist who later died. The
activation of this traffic light was already
scheduled before the accident.  yesterday and today
the southern nevada health district
will report on the most recent
efforts to distribute the vaccine
to date more than 34,000 nevadans
have been vaccinated with the first dose
of the coronavirus vaccine the
state remains in the first tier
distribution plan this includes the
inoculation of workers in the health sector,
first aid and
long-term medical centers,
mobilization to the second level is anticipated in the
coming weeks now we will move on with your
weather forecast there will be sun and
clouds today and for  the rest of the
week the maximum will be in the low 60
degrees have a good day I am I left
Jaramillo and this was news n  ow in Spanish
[Music]